[Music]
our next president will face the
challenge of rebalancing our
over-militarized approach to national
security
since the end of the cold war we've
relied too heavily on our military
in the conduct of foreign policy we've
reduced funding for our diplomats
and eliminated organizations that help
us shape attitudes about our policies
but the threats we're now facing need
our military to focus on their military
functions
engaging through diplomacy and other
civilian means
shapes the international environment by
organizing allies
getting institutions to set standards
and negotiating agreements
we need more diplomats out in the world
meeting with civil society groups
bearing witness to tragedies being part
of the conversation in local languages
evaluating asylum and visa applications
seizing opportunities as they arise
because that is how we build receptivity
to american problems
in short we need more civilians across
many government agencies
thinking and acting creatively to use
the tools of our free society
to advance our interests what do you
think the greatest national security
challenge facing the united states is
let us know in our poll also please let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei